bon
bonjour bienvenue dans diagonale le son
est bien aujourd'hui nous allons voir
encore un math élémentaire jean luc tout
à fait stéphane nous allons voir donc
aujourd'hui le mat fonds et cavaliers
contre roy alors c'est le match le plus
compliqué des maths alimentaire le mat
roi tour qui est expliqué dans une autre
leçon est relativement savent le
matériel de fous aussi et celui ci il
est vraiment complexe et c'est vraiment
pas facile du tout on est donc celui ci
demande un peu plus attention et donc
celui ci est aussi très instructif pour
vraiment savoir jouer avec des pièces
aux échecs et savoir un peu comment les
pièces se déplace donc là on a une
position par exemple sur l'échiquier on
voit un cavalier qui se déplacent comme
ça on va avoir tout de suite
simplement nous mettre la régie qui
l'ont peu de cran voilà donc le cavalier
sur la case aux cinq qui peut aller sur
toutes ces cases donc le déplacement
typique du cavalier donc les qui fait
dès qu'on appelle des rosaces voilà des
cristaux rosa c ldl virtuel on va dire
dans toutes les directions
il ya plusieurs façons de décrire le
mouvement du cavalier bon ça on le voit
dans le son sur le déplacement des
pièces on peut le rappeler tout
simplement infections il ya le elle est
aussi simplement le câble et sur la case
la plus jeune à deux cases de sa pièce
de départ et de la couleur opposée
il ya deux cases et sur la couleur
opposée et toutes les cases qui sont on
voit bien ici tous les cases qui sont à
distance deux de la caisse de départ et
qui sont ici sur les cases blanches
alors qu'il le cavalier lui même sur une
classement
ça c'est la version était
mathématisation mathématiques et moi je
version littéraire voilà donc voilà donc
le cavalier qui se déplace donc en elle
et le fou donc on va reporter sur le fou
qui est sûr à 15 h 6 qui quant à lui se
déplace donc en diagonale donc comme
l'émission donc le fou voilà qui qui va
donc en diagonale d'autant qu'à ce qui
le souhaitent donc deux pièces qui ont
des déplacements complètement différents
mais qui doivent combiner leurs actions
puisque chacune d'elles ne peut pas maté
droite vers ce seul voilà alors à noter
très important dans cette leçon revenir
dessus c'est que il faut que le cas il
ya une foule soit complémentaire et donc
le fou ici par exemple étant des cases
noires c'est très important
eh bien le cavalière et c'est aussi de
le placer sur une case moi parce que
comme ça
comme on voit ici le fou contre wall e
lui les cases noires indique le cavalier
lui contrôler les cases blanches et on
voit bien qu'ici le roi noir et bien ne
peut pas aller sur toutes ces cases
j'essaie simplement de les marquer en
rouge et donc il est bloqué dans ce tout
petit triangle ici fort alors parce
qu'il ya association entre le fou 15
mois et le cavaly case blanche
donc quand vous avez un fou de cases
noircies votre cavaliers sur place
blanche et il va pas y rester longtemps
quand il faut pas qu'ils y restent
longtemps cercle olive évidemment le cas
il va devoir bouger mais très
certainement quand il bougeait bien en
deux coups il faut que très vite il
retrouve une case de la même couleur du
fou qui soit plus avantageuses que ça
casse précédente mais j'adore le permis
va sauter de deux pas toujours pour
retrouver la couleur du fou afin de
toucher les 40 - ce qui est important ça
de retenir ces cavaliers donc qui est
sûr qu'à soir contrôle des cases
blanches et un cavalier sur cases
blanches contrôle des cases noires et
qu'il faut être complémentaire avec le
exactement puisque
dans cette position s'était ralliée été
placé sur une pièce blanche ils
contrôleraient des cases noires et donc
salée serait éventuellement des cases de
fuite pour le roi sur laquelle g8
alors on va voir tout de suite avec cet
exemple simplement voir le match voilà
donc ce que ça va être rapide première
leçon la leçon de maths
donc ce qui est très important donc pour
gagner donc avec un fouet un cavalier
contrat roi donc la chose essentielle
c'est de savoir où matt et le roi
adverse
donc la réponse à cette question c'est
le coin de la case du foie de coin de la
couleur du fou dont on ne peut mater le
roi adverse d'un final fou cavalli
contre roye que dans le coin de la
couleur du fond c'est à dire que si le
roi noir se retrouver de ce côté là eh
bien vous pourrez vous en persuader vous
même vous verrez qu'avec fouet cavaliers
on peut pas forcer le mac on ne peut pas
porter le matin c'est impossible c'est
bizarre mais c'est comme ça il faut
mettre le roi adverse 2 du côté la
pelouse ce qui est le cas là et on va
voir tout tout de suite le mat comme en
force le match jean luc dans cette
position donc là le mat donc arrive très
rapidement comme le roi est donc dans le
petit triangle on verra ça tout à
l'heure on joue roger six ans ferme le
roi qui qui est en face du roi adverse
mais ce roi qui ne peut pas donc qui ne
peut pas s'échapper
puisque cette case est contrôlé par le
fou le roi n'a plus qu'une seule case
c'est la case à schwyz
voilà alors maintenant donc il faut
jouer un petit coup de cavaliers de la
vallée toujours pas et donc le voilà
c'est ce qu'on disait il va pas y rester
longtemps sur une case blanche le
cavalier parce qu'il fait on voit bien
que là il joue deux fois enfin il ya
double emploi entre le foot cavaliers
donc ça aide pas versé la même case
c'est pas la peine à contrôler deux fois
dans cette finale donc il va falloir que
ce cavalier il se rapproche de grains
noirs sur une case noire en italie sur
215 plantations donc aussi important
c'est que dans cette position quand on
est comme ça on voit très bien que si on
faisait le coup fou
j'ai cet échec il attaque le roi le roi
vient ici et là il faudrait pour en vue
de faire échec du cavalier en imagine la
peau on imagine donc amat un match mais
existerait avec un cavalier qui serait
soit sur cette case donc sur la case et
6,75 à 7 soit sur les 15 h 6 voilà donc
le cavalier ne peut pas y aller en un
coup c'est pas possible
donc il faut préparer donc le plaçant du
cavalier à l'avant ce soit le gabarit et
bien sûr la case 17 oui le roi encore
une fois obligé de bouger et l'a donc
comme on l'indiqué le cavalier bien sûr
lacazette 6g loin le roi d'opti en échec
par le cavalier ne peut toujours pas
fuir donc sur la quasi faillite à cause
du fond il est obligé d'aller en acheter
8 est là donc il ya maintenant un coup
on voit que lecavalier en rêve si ce
contrôle ces deux cases le roi contre
cette case
donc il faut faire échec au roi c'est
facile et c'est très facile il faut
faire tout simplement fou g7
hélas émeutes hélas ces échecs les mains
donc le roi dans le roi noir qui n'a
plus de gaz
il applique à tout est contrôlé par
volume dans la mer et à terre par
l'adversaire voilà à womé audemat pour
finir nous allons voir d'autres exemples
suivants quoi passer les options donc
l'exemple suivant
donc on va revenir quand on la met dans
la rentrée dans la technique qui va nous
intéresser pour tous est le roi sur sur
son coin voilà tout à fait donc là nous
avons ce qu'on appelle la technique du
grand triangle donc la technique
rentrions que ça c'est un mot qui qui
m'est très cher donc le grand tio
triangle dans le temps qu'on dira par
rapport au coin on doit mater le roi le
grand triangle c'est ce triangle là donc
c'est le triangle qui est délimité par
c'est toutes ces cases la part la
diagonale du fou par sa grande diagonale
là on a ce qu'on appelle le grand
triangle le roi noir et dans le grand
triangle
c'est une première étape pour mater le
roi donc là on voit sur son vent levé
les flèches on constate que le fou et
lecavalier ont une action combinée c'est
à dire que là on voit le fou et le
cavalier donc en une action combinée
c'est à dire que le fouet sur cases
noires donc ils contrôlent les cases
noires ces reconduites à leur voile et
le cam indiqué également sur cases
noires contrôle lui les cases blanches
voilà donc là on voit que le roi dans
plus roi adverse ne peut déjà pas sortir
de cette zone à 7 c'est donc de ce grand
triant si on rapproche le roi par
exemple par à-coups comme roy le sac le
roi vient ici il ya on va passer donc au
prochain exemple qui s'intitule tout
simplement le moyen triangle c'est à
dire qu'on peut jouer ce coup là et
gagner donc on dire réduire donc la vue
d'une branche on est passé de ce
triangle à celui là en fait un four
c'est ont contrôlé on contrôlait bien
cette cette barrière ici et bien
maintenant on est passé on a enlevé
cette barrière et hop on a gagné un
petit un peu comme avec les deux fous
droite
exactement donc un petit peu la même
méthode donc on va passer à l'exemple
suivant l'exemple suivant donc on
revient à tout type en arrière donc là
on a ce qu'on appelle le moyen triangle
donc le moyen triangle
c'est ça c'est ce qu'on vient de dire
pour toujours ce qu'on remarque encore
une fois c'est ce qu'on vise tout à
l'heure c'est c'est cette
complémentarité donc très important de
bien que lecavalier et d'un même couleur
que le fou ici et c'est là qu'il ya plus
puissant puisque là ils contrôlent les
cases blanches complémentaire de
l'action du fou c'est complémentaire ici
avec ce four ici kibuye contrôler les
cases de couleurs opposées et donc qui
empêche le roi noir du coup de
s'échapper alors choses importantes
aussi c'est que lorsque l'on en arrive
donc à cette phase de moyens triangle on
peut dire que le roi adverse
donc si on regarde toutes les cases que
ces deux pièces contrôle on peut dire
que le roi adverse et étendu et il est
emmurée mais de manière définitive
voilà donc le fouet le cavalier
contrôler toutes les cases en noir qui
sont importantes et on voit que si on ne
touche pas à ses pièces le roi blanc
donc dans cette position le roi noir
plutôt peut pas sortir ne va pas pouvoir
bouger ailleurs que sur les cases en
jaune c'est à dire que même sans le roi
blanc on le tient il est coincé après
bon à l'arc le roi viennent parce que
les deux pièces peuvent pas bouger si
lecavalier bougeait bien une case
blanche deviennent accessibles et il va
s'échapper
et si le fou sort de sa des gones allait
bien il va pas pareil va pouvoir six
échappés donc il faut que le roi après
joue son rôle bras blancs mais en
attendant ces deux pièces suffisamment
fermer le roi de merde tout à fait donc
on rapproche le roi le classique à
redire on joue avec ses pièces en joue
par équipe
ea prévoit ici on imagine parle que sur
un coup comme moi là on peut passer à
l'étape suivante c'est à dire le petit
triangle c'est l'étape finale donc le
roi et dans le dernier triangle et ça
c'est la position donc on va voir ça
c'est la position ça revient plus ou
moins la position que nous avons vu tout
à l'heure tout à fait que c'est à dire
donc cette position ou
le petit triangle il est facile dans le
brouhaha mon bon coin du fou en plus
dans mon coin du fou donc ça c'est la
dernière étape avant de mater le roi
adverse
donc là ça va très rapidement on bouge
le roi échec le roi bouge et ont fait
échec et mat
donc là on a le petit triangle donc la
sas et les techniques élémentaires il ya
d'autres techniques qui se rajoute en
plus autant dire que c'est quand même ça
laisse quand même pas mal de
possibilités pour apprendre mais il faut
quand même faire attention quand on est
un grand triangle par exemple c'est pas
facile c'est pas facile il ya ya cette
histoire de triangle qui est possible et
c'est sûr mais là maintenant on va
passer
je crois à jean-luc donc une
démonstration de maths complète à partir
d'une position très défavorable pour les
blancs et on va voir tout le
problématique quand le roi ordinaire ça
arrive aller vers le mauvais coin voilà
et c'est là qu'il faut connaître aussi
la technique parce que là on sort même
de cette problématique du triangle et il
faut connaître cette suite le quasiment
sur le bout des doigts si on veut
arriver à mater le roi assez facilement
c'est une histoire ou erwan ward ont
choisi la meilleure défense il va dans
le mauvais points qui permet pas de
maths et comment on fait pour l'année en
cours et ensuite on va voir c'est pas si
simple qu'il faut le savoir on va mettre
la position pour expliquer un petit peu
plus sa position dans lequel dans la
position idéale
bon alors là donc là on a mis une nation
un ami une position
très défavorable on va dire oui on va
dire la position la plus compliquée pour
mater c'est-à-dire pour l'art on voit
que que le roi le fouet les cavaliers
sont très éloignées le roi noir est au
centre donc bien placé bien placé
puisqu'il est loin de tous les coins
alors quelle va être la défense déjà
qu'elle va être justement le roi noir
c'est que il va se faire mater silva se
rapprocher donne des points décisifs
c'est à dire ce coin ici à 1
ou alors le coin ici je suis alors
évidemment il va pas aller vers ces
coins là pour se faire enfermer
mais il va être safe en allant
évidemment plutôt de ce côté là puisque
ce côté-là gars le roi il pourra pas
mais il va aller effectivement du grand
côté ici sur cette case ici à 8 ça va
être la défense du roi noir qui va aller
là bas et on va voir que après il faut
le ramener d'ici il va falloir leur
année soit dans ce coin-là swan ce point
là et c'est pas ça c'est pas simple mais
il ya une technique
donc on va on va le voir tout de suite
avant les premiers coups non mais on
sent trahi le roi normale pour les
affaires donc le roi bouge on me wade ne
s'est pas facile parce que comme il est
au centre
il empêche maintenant un drap blanc de
deux heures d'avancé bon mais il faut il
faut ramener les autres pièces il va
falloir que cavalli s'amène il va
falloir que le plus actif sans doute
aussi un jour ou l'autre on sur le
cavalier pour l'histoire le bras noirs
liv est temps que tu ne déloge pas moi
je reste au centre j'essaie de tenir le
plus longtemps la règle des 50 trouve à
s'appliquer
ils fouillent cavaliers donc faut quand
même
le rappeler c'est que lorsque le dernier
pion été manger aux échecs lorsqu'il ya
eu la dernière prise de pions ou la
dernière avancée de pions en bois
remater l'adversaire on a cinquante
couples pour mater l'adversaire sans
plus de pièces non sans préciser l'heure
l'opération permis piéton pourrait pas
mater ces machines est donc on va voir
la suite
donc un petit coup ici pour centraliser
un peu mieux le roi roues et deux à
quatre mois c'est pas facile comme en
arrive à des logiciels va falloir que
car il joue son rôle
on va voir que ce qui techniquement un
petit échec ensuite le roi au centre
voilà une petite idée simplement on voit
très bien que le carrier de l'opposer à
la couleur du trou en fin de l'année
couleur que le fou donc contrôler les
cases opposé la couleur du foot et on
voit que maintenant grâce à l'action
commune des pièces et bien déjà toutes
les cases centrale
non il ya échec aura évidemment et tout
les cas centrale malins sont interdits
au roi noir
donc il va falloir qu'il sort du centre
déjà donc ça va être le premier une
première victoire pour les blancs et
comme il doit sortir du centre tout en
essayant de se rapprocher de ce bois là
parce qu'on a vu que c'était plus
favorable il faut pas qu'ils aillent
n'importe où donc il va falloir qu'ils
fassent attention au vent f400 rallye
semaine dans le fou un peu d'attentes en
fait c'est un coup d'attendre
il faut que le roi bouge en design
pourquoi on aime 5 toujours pareil parce
qu'il veut aller de ce côté là
évidemment il sait que c'est ça la case
un peu difficile là pour mater pour les
peaux l'adversaire maintenant on
centralise le roi et voilà ça y est le
roi noir alors il a hissé le roi noir
que s'il est ce côté là il va se faire
enfermer d'allant des points qu'est-ce
que là on va avoir cette histoire de
triangle assez assez rapidement et ici
il va avoir du mal à y aller parce que
toi sont simplement le cavalier
l'empêchent déjà d'aller là donc ça va
être serré très difficile pour lui et si
après ils cherchent à s'échapper par là
avec le fou on va arriver à l'empêcher
d'y aller donc il faut qu'ils c'est
chaud s'échappe voilà il s'échappe vers
le coin le plus difficile le coin le
mauvais point pour mater on y arrive un
final une erreur et on est dans une
sorte déjà de petits de petits triangles
donc maintenant évident on centralise le
roi il faut que le roi joue son rôle
maximum donc globalement logique va
plutôt vers le haut
blanc quitte échec bon la ceni c'est un
peu renvoie déjà là on ya déjà un petit
peu ce triangle kehl avec le cavaly qui
contrôle cette case leroy qui va sans
doute ensuite venir ici on ne va pas
trop vite j'ai justement très une astuce
c'est dans cette position donc le
fouetter vallier d'autres sont quand
même placé sur les mêmes couleurs donc
voilà encore une chose qui revient qui
récurrents votre carrière bien que ces
deux pièces en étant placé sous leur
contrôle déjà toutes les cases en rouge
mais encore en voilà tout ça donc on
commence petit à petit rasta les donc
derrière une barrière face au roi
adverse exactement une barrière une
défense ont gagné de l'espace avec le
roi des cinq videmment le bois noir en
pêche laurent blanc de prendre trop
l'espace il faut empêcher maintenant ce
roi de s'échapper trop on était là c'est
le temps il ya le travail était un peu
loin mais n'en voyez bien qu'il était
plus au contact au niveau de ces casses
contrôle et donc il est fort le ramener
sur une case moi beaucoup plus proche du
roi adverse pour contrôler des cases
blanches à côté lebrun s'échappe
on aurait peut-être attendre juste un
instant dans cette position on aurait
également pu quand même joué un coup
comme voilà qui est aussi assez
raisonnable puisque la vie raisonnable
aussi parce que le roi dame fait office
de barrière naturelle faso pour adverse
avec le fou aussi tout à fait sourire et
ses joies de la possibilité en fait
c'est pas tu sais pas trop ce qui nous
attirait cela on va on va surtout voir
le moment où le roi va être à la bande
donc voilà ça y est il est à la banda
des croix c5 et maintenant il reste d'un
mauvais coin voilà ça c'est le mauvais
coin on pourra pas le maté ici son gros
coin d'ailleurs si oui c'est mon bébé
c'est le mauvais coin pour les blancs
qui veulent mater et c'est le bon coin
pour les noirs qui veulent éviter d'être
dans le mauvais coin tout à fait des
coudes attentes
voilà 7 3 6 6 3 à 8 ans voilà maintenant
ça y est on y est il est d'un mauvais
coin on valoir tout de suite voilà et
vous pourrez vous persuadé qu'on peut
pas maté le roi est par exemple si je
vous fous à 7 est bien y'a pas tout
puisque le roi peut pas à cause du
cavalier
jouer d'ailleurs mon train tu peux
essayer doué on peut essayer de mater
tout simplement leur foi cette voie là
et la pâte
voilà c'est pas ta partie est finie donc
c'est pas mal ses potes donc ces parties
nulles le grave échec ne peut pas aller
sur cette case puisque le fou contrôle
et ne peut pas aller sans s'être case
puisque le cavalier contrôler la classe
b vite
tout à fait donc on va revenir et l'a
donc dans cette position très importante
on voit que finalement donc le roi noir
et dans le mauvais coin
oui je peux mais ne peut pas le maté
c'est impossible
on va voir aussi comment il va descendre
tout en bas donc case par case comment
il va descendre dans le monde va
l'amener dans le mauvais coin voilà donc
ouais ben voilà c'est ça que c'est quand
même ça qui nous intéresse c'est ça qui
nous intéresse c'est de voir la descente
la chute du roi on va dire voilà donc
très important si on sait pas à partir
de cette position si on sait pas mater
les fous et cavaliers vous n'arriverez
jamais parce que si les noirs savent
aller dans le mauvais coin
et bien vous pouvez pas vous matez donc
il faut absolument connaître cette la
suite qu'on va vous montrer qui est une
suite à canaliser qui est la plus rapide
et la plus simple qui précède une
méthode assez assez clair et net
donc voilà c'est évidemment c'est clair
que la méthode du roi sur la banque
combinée à la méthode du grand du moyen
et du petit triangle
est très utile walter que c'est très
utile puisque sa complète donc la
formation classique on va dire il ya
quand même un débat mais je pense que ça
s'est quand même été très très important
qui a été confirmé par tous les
spécialistes dans les finales on va voir
ça tout de suite alors qu'avaient les v6
échec au moins voilà donc le roi
commence sa descente il peut pas venir
sur la case b8 parce que c'est contrôlé
par fou alors ça si classique lorsqu'on
va trouver tout le long de cette
technique
on le reverra tout de suite c'est cette
position tout à fait caractéristique le
fou empêche le roi noir de sortir le
cavalier faisant échec ici on voit qu'il
va créer ici une petite barrière avec le
fou qui va empêcher le roi une fois
qu'il sera ici de revenir de s'échapper
ils envoient déjà qui va être obligé de
descendre un petit peu et le roi ici
très très bien placé aussi qui contrôle
lui-même toutes ces cases là et on voit
que l on l'amène dans un petit coup
c'est un petit couloir une espèce de
couleur qu'on a créé de toutes pièces
avec notre fou d'autres cavaliers notre
vie notre moi voilà donc kamel et b6
leroy gyan à cette menace se joue à peu
d'attentes faut temporiser on se fout et
fiat on temporise c'est ça voilà le roi
va devoir encore une fois des sens
puisque ces cases sont contrôlés macase
baby doll eyes habite le roi de la
descente sur la casa 6 obligé et la
foule forcé et la fougue et 8 donc on
contrôle cette case et le roi va devoir
descendre encore un petit peu plus donc
ça c'est typique
il faut absolument que ce moment là le
fou joue à plein il faut forcer le roi à
aller encore plus bas donc là il est
obligé donc le roi des sens voilà alors
là maintenant on fait une petite larme
et l on va la relancer l'axé essentiel
très important très important dans cette
position là quand le roi effectivement
s'est échappé on voit que là si on
revient avec le fou par exemple donc on
l'empêché évidemment d'aller plus loin
et du coup le roi va remonter par contre
donc on n'aura pas progressé non
maintenant il faut bouger le cavalier
aux cavaliers a joué son oeuvre
et comme on l'a dit le cahier du tic sur
les cases de la même couleur que le fou
donc il va falloir la mener en deux casa
des cases plus utile et que quelqu'un en
plus utile que cette case là qui va
permettre de créer une petite barrière
un cran plus haut que la première
barrière con
on a parlé tout à l'heure voilà pour
amener le roi qui petit à petit vers le
vers le bas et on va voir maintenant
c'est crucial effectivement le mouvement
de cavaillé qu'on voit tout de suite et
thématiques cavaliers en d5 ici avec
l'idée qu'on peut venir sur cette case
là contrôlé cette case là et on voit
bien qu'avec le fou ici mais le roi va
être obligé de descendre et le roi suite
va venir reprendre sa position standard
que l'on vient ici donc on va descendre
d'un cran
donc il faut le faire en deux temps
cavalli sicable hélas hélas c'est là
qu'est le problème
deux solutions pour les non-membres
avoir l'appui standard il revient vers
le bon mais je me rapproche le plus de
mauvais côtés donc ça c'est le plus tôt
la position le coût normal on va dire
rester vers le petit coin voilà donc là
le cavalier vient sur la case bkp échec
le roi bouge et en plus tout simplement
maintenant rester devant le cavalier
dans là puisqu'on a gagné ce voilà ce
petit bout de thé ou café
alors ce qui était intéressant aussi
c'était de voir ce qui pouvait se passer
après trois à quatre alors valoir après
on va d'abord regarder la méthode
classique et ensuite on va voir cette
suite
cette suite qu'il faut contrôler de
façon extrêmement dans les choix de
cette solution se simplifient qu'on dira
elle s'explique assez rapidement donc on
joue alors on peut le penser quand même
droit ces cinq rois b3 par exemple qui a
balayé la haute-vallée la barre
voilà et la fout ici mais là on peut on
peut dire qu'après ce coup très
important fut f4 le roi ne peut plus de
ne peut plus échapper il est
complètement murray et là on se
rapproche de la technique principal du
contraignant tout à fait ça y est voilà
comment exactement on va donc revenir à
la halle à dire à la ténacité on va dire
le coût de nas il revient
en plus haut voilà le roi reste essaye
de rester mais on les chasse il doit
partir on descend donc lula il doit s'en
aller ici puisque la casa si ces
contrôles et montent ils essayent de
rester de se rapprocher toujours de ce
coin lors de ce coin là mais non de
chasse à la salle y est et on a en a on
voit qu'on a la même position tout à
l'heure avec les deux cas ce qu'on
contrôle et en os cette fois les
contrôles ici donc voilà donc on voit
bien qu'on a gagné voyez bien que la
position et elle amène avec le roi qui
étaient ici qui est passée là et le
cavalier quitter ici qui est passée là
donc on a gagné de gaz vers le bas on la
poussait on la puce et on la poussait
ont pas beaucoup de coups donc le roi
descend à 4 et on refait la même manière
et maintenant on attend voilà donc le
roi à dessin et la fameuse manoeuvre de
cavaliers donc toujours très important
celle qu'on a vue de freineur le
cavalier dont qui se dirige sur la case
d3 donc hissé des régions a case d3 pour
aller tout sur la base d'un contrôle et
la gaza car exactement et poussé le roi
donc toujours plus bas jusque jusqu'à
l'avant donc là on voit bien qu'au nez
dans le monde triangle et qu'on revoie
la même technique on va la faire
jusqu'au bout
voilà donc trois à quatre donc 3 à 4 le
coût important cavaliers p23 trois rois
ces trois ça y est on pousse le roi
jusqu'en va donc cette case on voit bien
qu'on se rapproche du bon gras gaz et
comprenait par le cavalier voilà c'est
le bon coin c'est le coin de la couleur
du fou n'a sonné dans ce qu'on appelle
le petit triangle le roi vient à deux
rois ces deux droits vian à 3 fou fou
fou c'est chirac hasek et l'a donc le
roi ne peut pas s'enfuir parce que par à
4 puisque le cavalier contrôle
voilà on a en encore gagné de gaz par
rapport à tout à l'heure donc un peu de
tout à l'heure c'était ces deux cases la
queue contrôles et fouilles cavaliers
ensuite ça a été ces deux gars là et
maintenant ce sont des ces deux gaz là
contrôlé par le fou et par le cavalier
ici voilà donc on voit bien qu'on
retrouve la même position
ici le roi était ici ensuite il est
descendu là et ensuite la et donc on
répète comme ça la technique comme ça
jusqu'au bout donc le roi vient à deux
est là donc on termine on va dire par le
par a
au petit matin peu artistique il ya
plusieurs solutions pour mateo beaucoup
d'attentes on peut jouer à coude est
temps de prendre le petit triangle de
manière plus directe plus simple mais
sinon on peut faire cette petite méthode
cassé jolifou des six leroy viala
faciale but de casse pour le wild
dassault on place le cavalier l'a donc
le royal n'a plus qu'une seule case la
case à 2 voilà on fait échec
ils n'ont pas le choix le cavalier en c1
attaque le roi de hip hop à fuir parce
que le faut contrôler voilà il doit
aller dans le coin est dans la boîte et
là on va commencer à réfléchir deux
petites secondes
il ya matin recours le roi ne peut pas
aller là puisque le cavalier contrôle
il faut faire échec au roi donc s'il
faut jouer le coup fou fou décisif où
des 6 e 5 voilà et c'est là et c'est
matt donc le fou attaque le roi est donc
là je crois qu'on a bien compris comment
mater le roi d'un mois voilà on va
revenir encore une fois sur cette
position je dirais danse est dans ce cas
de matha la bande nous avait quoi cette
position critique donc qui était voilà
ici le fameux voilà ce que la belle
année cinq ici standard ou là le roi
peut encore choisir donc quand on a vu
qu'ils remontaient on a bien de voir la
technique jusqu'au bout on l'a déjà vu
mon va leur montrer s'il vient à quatre
c'est ça qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est tout simplement n'est pas pressé
on joue d'abord le roi ici et ensuite
une fois qui s'échappe
eh bien il s'échappe pas ça a l'air
bizarre mais il faut bien calculer son
truc et c'est là qu'on voit la
complémentarité des deux pièces trop et
cavaliers en impuissante
on va quand même sur la classe c 2 et on
a bien contrôlé cases blanches et il
suffira de venir avec le fou soit là ça
dépendra le roi mais sois là soit là
pour contrôler via le reste et ça y est
enfermé le droit complètement danse
danse le mauvais côté
alors elle fait ici comme ça et là on
voit bien flèche un peu en trop ici on
voit bien que le roi ici et ici
contrôlée par euros adverse ici par le
cavalier voilà est ici par le fou donc
qu'il est obligé de revenir dans le coin
est fatale et on voit que la technique
était imparable on peut même montrer qu
alain cavalier
donc là je crois qu'on arrive à la fin
et donc le cavalier qui a le cavalier le
fou qui ont leur rôle à la fois donc
d'une paire de fou puisqu'il pellizari
va contrôler donc le roi en diagonale
exactement et de manière un peu plus
complexe arrive quand même à jouer le
rôle d'une tour puisque finalement on a
trouvé une technique pour de faire
descendre de faire glisser un roi
legendre d'abord noyade lors de
l'abandon de tout à fait exactement
exactement donc vous en vous je pense
que les spectateurs laon seront beaucoup
plus maintenant sur ce déplacement de
ces deux pièces
voilà donc très important je crois qu'on
a tout montré bon après évidemment il
faut s'entraîner donc on le conseillera
jamais assez donc on peut s'entraîner
mais le ski pratique c'est contre
logiciel évidemment parce qu'il s'énerve
pas il est calme et en général il faut
jusqu'au bout oui mais entraînez vous
avec deux avec vos amis à mes amis sinon
voilà exactement
voilà donc faut qu'il y ait très
important à connaître dans les maths
élémentaire à bientôt dans une autre
leçon
oui